it is the reality of ever everything
ends right
so understanding that uh
is is only beneficial for me
you know i think the most important
thing is and i struggle with this is
just enjoying the time you have before
it
ends there's a beginning and then
there's enjoyment and then there's the
end and then
it's it's sort of like god i was
on the you know
my old therapist who i fired can you
fire a therapist
yeah okay i remember he stood up like he
was standing up like he was taking a
piss
and he goes you got one foot in the past
your right foot's here in the present
and you're pissing on the future oh no
you got one foot in the past one
in the future and you're pissing on the
present mm-hmm and he had his you know
showing you like
now and he had pulled his pants down he
didn't pull his pants down that would
have been appropriate
and you're like that's it you're fired
although for him it might have been
appropriate because
that was the kind of guy that was the
kind of guy who i'm sitting there and
he's eating a subway sandwich and he's
just devouring
his do you mind if i eat i'm like yeah
it's my hour i'm paying you a lot of
money
and he's like oh i didn't say that yeah
sure he's like mm-hmm mm-hmm
okay yeah this is over zoomers oh this
was uh this is
this is years ago i let him go after
that i felt like you know what this is
we're too comfortable he's too calm he's
too comfortable
i'm uncomfortable this is not
comfortable yeah you're you're shooting
with the bathroom door open now
yeah but do you enjoy the moment are you
going on set every day and enjoying the
days
i have gotten better at it and i've
gotten much better at it
since bear arrived bear your son bears
my son bear sullivan what's his middle
name maxwell bear maxwell
i was kind of lobbying for maximus
but it was too bear sullivan
yeah i think of like this is comes mine
and starting linebacker number 32 bear
maxwell
the 265 foot five senior from
you know absolutely absolutely is he big
for his age
that's he's 10 months old and he's
wearing 18-month clothing
so he's he's he's very large for his age
but the the since he since he has
arrived
all the paradigms have shifted in our
anus in an instant
and it's been very difficult to um to
realign
and to ground myself in the new reality
that is everything